are you ready Pocoyo
here not still angry about the way we've
represented you in that Garfield where
you are yeah well I'm sure other
contestant will be happy
go find out what was wrong at the Super
Mario Brothers movie and sorry you got
to punch those boxes just punch of open
just you know yeah go in there and find
out the comedic antics that await you
I'll hold them down you want to knee him
into the junk yeah fuck you guys bag him
this is pop quiz hot shot it to general
I'm the Nostalgia Critic and ever since
I was a child I always want to play
games quoting movies and TV with my
friends the only problem was I had no
friends well now that I have power I can
take my friends by force with the help
of my new pal general anaesthetic I can
kidnap all the friends I want and force
them to answer questions a might Saved
by the Bell style sent there will be
laughs trivia those disturbing cartoons
that give you night terrors but most of
all there will be fun the laughter and
joy will last however long I want
heads up America or this is pop quiz
hotshot
welcome back to pop quiz hotshot or as I
like to call it general anesthetics last
show what the hell man you kind of
kidnapped two more inappropriate people
to bring on this show how'd you even
find these two together were you dating
were you dating fine whatever okay so
like ChristianMingle long enough you're
bound to run into someone who just
happens to have the same enemies that
you do you're not funny and nobody loves
you
let's do this we get to talk about you
guys as if everybody doesn't know who
you are right now Brad it says here you
used to be the host of a game show I did
welcome to purgatory yeah so how was
that I surprisingly I just read the
comments Carl or uncle yo if that is
your fake name yeah yeah yo okay it was
too hard to add any more layers to your
name I'm sure it says here that you're
apparently a comedian tell me about that
make me laugh asshole yeah yeah you
don't need to do that my best no you see
I asked you a question so and we haven't
even started yet this is just where we
get to know or pain in the ass you are
which are demonstrating very well right
now by the way does the noise upset you
a touch well a bit yeah okay fuck you no
no no fuck you both that guy's got a gun
he will shoot you he has done it in the
past he knows so we're good
okay goddamn it just saw how the rules
work each contestant is asked a series
of questions involving the sounds of
quotes
if the contestant does not know the
answer but can make the Nostalgia Critic
laugh ten points are still given but
look out for the spaciest
the first one to hit their buzzer when
they appear ends the round while the
other has to pay the penalty through
round two where the quotes get even
harder the winner with the most points
face off against the nostalgia critic
and a one-on-one match if the contestant
wins they walk out with a cash prize and
also their lives if they lose the cash
prize will be added to the next
contestants winning
well I guess it's kind of pointless to
give you any money because you know I
don't like either of you so why don't we
play for charity
just pick one Brad what's your charity I
am playing for Siamese rescue org and
flashing lights very nice I don't think
you need much money they seem to be
working fine on their own ah yo what is
your charity we've got Dan stop it
you know annoying you is child's play at
this point so I think I will follow in
the footsteps of some of my favorite
other Internet personalities of the
abridging community why don't I play for
child's play as well it's a charity that
tries to bring in relief to children in
hospitals by giving them used and new
video games very good and I am going to
do donorschoose.org that is a site that
gives money to classrooms and schools
that is looking to get just stuff that
every school should have new computers
updated books all sorts of great stuff
so wonderful charities we're just gonna
go right into it
breath what actors saying I'm singing in
the rain in a Clockwork Orange Malcolm
McDowell yes yo in the great Muppet
Caper
whenever the characters say they're
going to catch the villains red-handed
what is the reply what color are my
hands now their hands now sorry doesn't
count Oh someone doesn't know they're
Muppets cuz it hurt does it sting I hope
it does Brad finish this quote from love
story film I'm sure you'll love as well
love means never having to say you're
sorry
no I'm not but I'll give you the points
anyway wow I knew a love story question
yo what classic comedy head this line
and by the way you know when you're
telling these little stories here's a
good idea have a point big fish
no big is that even really a comedy
enough whiskey turns any tune hurtin
movie into a comedy you've clearly
already stolen his kitchen tiles so
really that Gavin ooh you're giving him
a new youuuu one ooh
I've lost way more than that your time
than you have I get the you get the you
given the points no no I be your
contestant was better Brad what actors
said missus really what actor said mrs.
Robinson you're trying to seduce me
aren't you
Dustin Hoffman yes I know my Ishtar yo
finish this Robert De Niro line
I have nipples Greg so do you no really
you're you don't I mean really fucker
it's cut some motherfuckers could you
milk me oh okay
bread in what movie did Christoph Waltz
say I got a bingo inglorious basterds
yes whooping great if he's actually said
if they go as well but the great deals
in that movie dog whooping that very
fast
yo what Disney actor famously shouted
you're really had trouble with this one
what does the actor famously shouted you
are a toy yeah yeah smile smile what
you're guessing bug's life or something
like that god damn it you don't need to
hit that no no no it's what actors said
it and as we both know Tom Hanks my
friend Tom Hanks Wow look at that 10 to
40 you're not doing so well yo you ain't
doing so well conjoined cats are gonna
be really excited see if the dragon
board reunion Brad
which Pirates of the Caribbean movie has
the line you best start believing in
ghost stories in this Turner you're in
one the first one I need a title the
curse of the Black Pearl close its curse
of the Black Pearl dad there's a flag
Brad all a cow given the yo in there
will be blood daniel plainview said I
drink your root beer true or false
I've got bread tight we shake yes yes
but you didn't answer true or false oh
I'm not gonna accept yeah given the
points take that question to him Brad
which actors said only a sip thinks in
absolutes in Star Wars Episode three
Heidi Christensen no it was Ilyn the
Gregor though I would giving you points
if you pointed out that's a fucking
absolute that he just said yo what's
warts integra movie had the line a man
is defined by his actions not his
memories Total Recall yes wrapped in the
Sandlot Scottie is offered some s'mores
when Scottie asked how can he have some
more of nothing
what is hands reply you're killing me
smalls yes can we just take a minute to
love that movie
Sandlot two was better you take his
points away right now that is I don't
care if you're joking you can't keep
them keep them note all right wake a bum
cape on three was the superior ones now
you're talking yo in saw what character
said live or die make your choice let
the game begin
I'm gonna go with ya the only
character's name that anyone knows from
that book really neither you're gonna
hit the buzzer no you both want to face
the penalty is that it well we don't
have enough costumes so look well I
think Brad hit the buzzer yeah Brad hit
the buzzer black boy there you go yeah
yeah cut jobs or ad that means uncle yo
you get to pay the penalty as a penalty
of my choosing and you know what it's
not so easy being hosts over here as
some of us know so I want
you to be the nostalgia critic yeah I
want you to wear the suit coat the hat I
want you to be in these burning lights
and see it's not so easy you want the
guy who's emceed over 50 cosplay
masquerades to cosplay do you want to
just hand me a doughnut and a milkshake
right now I'll take that you doing it
anyway
go get him to the costume Brad you get
to watch the spazzy cartoon it's gonna
be shocking and gory isn't it hey how do
you buddy
pretty sure I reviewed that and
masturbated to it several times well
congratulations you're the first
contestant to actually be more scary
than the spazzy cartoon you should be
very proud uncle yo
or should I say nostalgia oh yeah pretty
warm in that outfit huh at least I was
able to tie my own tie and didn't have
to say call me in to shoot dragon board
to tie your tie don't laugh at that I
like this one better
it was an outtake on demo reel maybe you
remember it no nobody remembers demo
reel and you know it we're gonna go into
round 2 this is where the questions get
a little harder I would say good luck to
both of you but yeah you're both here so
you have no luck Brad what movie
originated the often imitated line is it
safe Marathon Man yes
yo in 2001 a Space Odyssey a dying Hal
9000 sings a song it's called
what bicycle 4 - Wow III have both AC
and a bicycle built for it - how do you
know it's called a bicycle built for
duty never even gets that part of the
song I didn't know that's what it was
called until I said the car how do you
know that that's the original song title
hi everyone thinks it's everyone thinks
it's desi yes but how do you know what
in the grand scheme of life made you
have to listen to that song and be like
hey I should know this is the title so
that I remember the title so you don't
you're the greatest Doug to shop breath
in the 1969 movie The Italian Job what
actors said you were only supposed to
blow the bloody doors on Michael Caine
yes uncle yo finish this line from
Chinatown she's my sister and my
daughter kind of a big spoiler we're
giving away their but yes forget it it's
trying to tell don't worry Brad and what
DreamWorks film does an anime a duck say
we are noodle folk broth runs through
our veins dirty duck first of all you
raise your hand you don't have to do
that
second dirty duck you're right the full
title is down and dirty duck
that's our no no so good man yeah what's
up what's the plot to download us it's
about a losers it's insurance salesman
named Howard who can't get laid and so
he inherits a duck from a dead client as
that happens and there is an awesome
rockin soundtrack from two members of
the Turtles
and it is an adult film from the 70s
from the creators of Rugrats god dammit
I have to give you those points now fuck
I so cannot reward that so the bitch so
you more skin on that make that movie at
least one person will go see it yo what
comedy you had the Kevin Klein quote
it's kakuka Ken
kakuka coming to cook a cat kill me this
cold wanted
yeah I met her now news actually
fierce creatures same movie Brad in
Spaceballs when most star says just what
we need a druish princess
what is Barse reply she doesn't look
Jewish yes well shit funny she doesn't
look Jewish
oh sorry I thought you yelled shit
afterwards give him the points God would
have to be so fucking fun you asshole I
like the comedian over there
yo what David Lynch film features the
line of spice must flow
oh dude yes / - Wow loud voice wailing
my backgrounds are never the same caller
that tweeners its paws play play oh but
takes cause shut up no that don't
encourage him okay keep it courage yo
shut yo shut up I'm in charge of him now
she's mine
bye his heart will always be with me job
don't don't do not take that fist bump
back take that back what is that you
can't give my fist it's over here now
he's about to tuck away that's pretty
dirty both of you shut up
just just shut up we're gonna keep it to
answering questions and nothing else
don't you fucking dare don't you touch
that you mother cocksucking ass bitch
horn fuck I'm doing that we got the
light a little line so I said something
about your tongue
Brad finish this Salah line from Raiders
of the Lost Ark asks very dangerous hmm
yes they are Raiders of the Lost Ark if
it was a Temple of Doom question I would
get it it's the good one I'm so glad you
went first on that one one of two good
Indiana Jones movies Raiders and Temple
of Doom Last Crusade that's three this
is why you're not gonna betray the
Persia I'm screaming over here I'm
thinking the King Solomon's Mines Prince
of Persia - sandy vagina theater near
you what where am I
there's two of me one of him I'm in his
job none of this makes any goddamn sense
uncle yo in The Day the Earth Stood
Still what infamous words are used to
deactivate the robot Court I'm gonna go
with nano nano nano it's been a very
long time you know if there actually was
a crossover with Mork and Mindy in that
movie I may none of your fans would get
it I understand
Pinewood my fans are like 50 they'll get
the dirty duck reference let's see if
you get this record no points were you
brat
what actor famously chimed wax on wax
off in the Karate Kid this was a hard
question Pat Morita yes Pat marina
that wasn't hard Heather got really it
could have been Jackie Chan easy
question just more open Siamese cats in
bad boys Will Smith and Martin Lawrence
asked a gun man to back up put down the
gun and give them what okay Katherine
skittles no it's not the kick-ass
surprisingly close it's bubblicious and
some skittles I'm really shocked that a
person who knows the effortless song for
Daisy kind of knows his bad boys but
obviously you said no no you know what
song to this is more important rap which
Bill Murray characters said I'm a god
I'm not vegan Peter Venkman so not
because Phil Conners
and that means that the round is over
and it looks like we have uncle yo at 80
points and Brad at a hundred points that
means you will go on to the final round
uncle yo it gives me no joy in saying
this as 100% lie you must leave now
please take off that suit cuz I don't
want you to die so handsome
I've never seen it from this angle
what watch was gonna do now well be
right back where one hope goes up
against the other hosts in pop quiz
hotshot if you would like to be a
contestant a pop quiz hotshot and live
in the Chicagoland area send a video via
YouTube stating your name 8 and why you
think it would be a good competitive
welcome back to pop quiz hotshot Brad
welcome back sugar misty old friend
addicted to had no idea he actually do I
actually do you'll be facing off against
nostalgia critic on our final round I'll
be reading off seven questions the one
who answers almost correctly will win
this absolutely nothing it's a charity
show however $100 in cash will be sent
to the charity of your choice
fan damn tastic alright I'll be reading
how Christopher Walken quotes you have
to match the quote with the movie let us
begin
Brad this say Nova Bears country bears
correct critic who would have thought
Cena had a brain to damage name returns
correct
Brad two mice fell to a book of cream
but first of all gave up quickly and
drowned Mouse hunt incorrect critic the
way your dad looked at it is watch put
your brows right
Pulp Fiction correct Brad you do that
again stab you in the face
soldering iron Joe Dirt correct critic
Todd that's good tell that mean ocean
Joe there too incorrect
Brad fast as sub impulse to turn the
wheel quickly head on to the oncoming
car any home correct critic more more
power more do it license to kill
incorrect Brad what part of something
death didn't you understand balls of
fury correct critic dead well he was an
ass with ideas to bathroom
you don't kill - incorrect Brad ice it's
got a break dead zone correct critic you
want me to say what like I don't get it
is that it
Chile incorrect Brad I don't think about
that much with one shot anymore Mike G
Lee incorrect and finally critic put
some on your head get tunngle slide the
brains out trying to get it Shaylee
correct and the winner is
nicely done
how ironic really yes I can't really
drag you in
I can't general shoot him I finally
enjoy being a little show stay tuned
next time for another episode of pop
quiz that shot this is the first time
we've had an actual conversation I
rarely saw when you were hosts yeah yeah
and this is the most I've stood on my
tippy toes since the last time I hosted
pretty much yeah how's life been pretty
good I'm living large when kidnapping
more people for the show and yeah just
like old times
yes how's miss Stockholm doing she's
dead but see I never would have let that
slide as house eat your wait until
sweeps week